well I'm here as you heard is the parent
of a 20 year old son who suffers with
BPD I am here with his permission and he
has specifically asked me to share
anything about his situation or his
story that would be in any way helpful
to anyone else because as he put it if
there's anything that he can do to
alleviate someone else's suffering to
prevent them from having to go to the
depths that he has gone then he's happy
to do that so I am here with his
permission which I appreciate
tremendously you know the scary thing
about all of this is this is actually a
date for me and my husband to be here
today so you know this is our life now
and you know it's such a varied audience
you know there's clinicians there's
consumers there's you know socially
there's a little bit of everybody
there's parents family members but if
you're wondering who the parents are in
the in the audience in the group it's
very easy to tell we're the ones that
look like we've been hit but been run
over by a truck so it's very easy I
can't possibly convey my appreciation
for the work of the NEA BPD in ten
minutes but you will see that the impact
you will see the impact of that
organization on our family's trajectory
over the past five years as I explained
our story I also don't want to scare
anyone you know with our story I can
tell you that our story has a happy
ending so far so we can all breathe I
also want to apologize in advance to
anyone who may be offended or a bit put
off if I use a little bit of dark humor
I would not be able to stand before you
today without it so when I started
learning about BPD I often heard parents
or other people share the sentiment you
know and we've heard that today if only
we knew well you know
case with our son we knew we knew that
he was emotionally tremendously
sensitive from from the get-go that was
abundantly clear that his emotional
sensitivity level was very different
from the other kids on the playground
the other kids in the class the other
kids on the little league team little
things that meant nothing to someone
else
were devastating to him you know I think
of an example of when he was about four
and somebody a little kid was they were
doing a pretend game with ice cream
sandwiches they were pretending to have
ice cream sandwiches and the kid says to
him I'm gonna make a pile of ice cream
sandwiches and our child says oh me too
and they make their piles so then the
kid reaches over and he says he he says
I just ate all of your ice cream
sandwiches now remember these are
imaginary ice cream sandwiches nobody
has any our son was devastated
devastated one of our other children
might have reacted by saying you're an
idiot like what what is your problem you
know okay I'm gonna make myself twenty
million more but that just goes it's a
very small example of that emotional
sensitivity you know in elementary
school he did exceptionally well
very intelligent never had to do much
work teachers loved him he always
responded to the teachers because they
were consistent in their you know and
there are reactions with him and whatnot
you know and in middle school things
really that was the point when things
really started to unravel for him he
couldn't he couldn't manage to take the
bus home from school because picture a
middle school school bus at 2:30 in the
afternoon
you know sixth seventh and eighth
graders you know the decibel level the
chaos level there just that you know
couldn't happen so that's when we
started to see that
is he was being prevented from doing
things by his emotions we thought he
might do better in a very small
nurturing private school so he started
high school at a small nurturing private
school and on the very first day he came
home from school and he said nobody
cares that I'm there ok on Christmas day
of his freshman year I saw that he had
made cut marks on his leg like a little
like a pattern of cutting marks on his
legs yeah I had never seen anything like
that before
I had no frame of reference for what
could possibly be going on so I spoke to
his school counselor I got myself a book
on cutting we actually took him to a
psychologist at that point who advised
that we provide him with less of a
safety net and that he you know he's
able to experience the consequences of
his own actions more we noticed at that
time a marked increase in impulsivity
and in relationship instabilities he had
no stop instincts he would climb
anything climb trees climb electrical
towers climb to the top of BestBuy I
would show up at school and I'd run into
another mother and she would say oh I
saw that most recent video of your son
he is such a daredevil really what did
you see you know and you know some crazy
video that was on social media of him
you know climbing somewhere or something
so for the next couple of years as he
went through high school he continued to
excel academically and he continued to
have extremely volatile friendships
romantic entanglements it was just it
was a life of drama and and of crisis
you know it was it was increasingly
difficult for him because you know on
the one hand he's taking all these AP
classes
he's the varsity of the he's the captain
of the varsity cross country team junior
and senior years he's got all this and
at the same time he was experiencing
emotions that he couldn't handle
he took make pain medication for a
condition he had for the very first time
and that became a problem he started
down a path of hiding the fact that he
was seeking relief from his internal
turmoil in any way he could
thankfully he never had consistent
access to any one substance but his
entire life became an absolutely
impossible tightrope walk between this
high achieving student youth group
member etc and this overwhelming turmoil
he was cutting there was sexual
recklessness prescription drugs alcohol
you know throwing up
choking himself his self-harm escalated
you know I'd be driving him to school in
the morning and I'd look over and
realized that he had a red ring around
his neck and that he had been trying to
choke himself you know just all kinds of
things it was you know each day what we
were just what is going to happen today
are we going to school we're not going
to school everyone we together went to a
psychiatrist who helped him to try to
deal with the underlaying you know
anxieties he experienced but regardless
of you know there's general treatment
the self-harm and pulse of behavior
sexual recklessness continued his first
hospitalization occurred his senior year
I found him in a bloody bathtub he was
released after 24 hours he had a second
hospitalization shortly thereafter he
was in the hospital for 3 or 4 days and
then he was released self-harm and
impulsivity continued escalated and it
became increasingly varied creative and
lethal throughout his senior year of
high school we went to another physician
who initially thought he was bipolar
[Music]
asked him if he ever felt empty no never
never feel at have felt empty Damon
about my life his behaviors continued
there was no stopping the creative
self-harm until one day the physician
asked him
appointment and thankfully the physician
was very open to involving me in the
treatment because I could give insight
you know things that he couldn't see and
he asked our son have you ever felt
lonely
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding that was the
magic question talk about language our
son couldn't relate to the idea of
feeling empty but boy could he relate to
the idea of feeling lonely and that was
the magic that was the magic right there
that led to the BPD diagnosis you know
his response was every minute of every
day crushing loneliness so of course
having a diagnosis doesn't really
provide treatment however necessarily
but we still had an accurate diagnosis
we waited a month or so for an
appointment with the DBT therapist who
was able to confirm the diagnosis which
was great but they didn't have time they
didn't have room in their schedule to
treat him so we were just seeking
treatment we waited for a couple of
months to get a spot in the IOP and it
was just a miscommunication for how that
would all happen so he arrived all
excited the first day you know he
graduated from high school on a Friday
and he showed up at DBT at the IOP on
Monday and they said oh no you're just
here to be on the wait list for the DBT
program what so it was just a it was a
miscommunication
he was eventually referred to a DB ter
the DBT therapist with whom he went
through one cycle of a DBT class it's
interesting he felt that it wasn't a
great fit with that particular
individual he said he felt treated like
a curiosity and he actually said to me
said mom what I need is skills I don't
need to be fascinating to someone I
don't need to be interesting to somebody
I need to know what to do so that you
know that was very telling that's how I
remember the psychologist telling us
that our son had a prefrontal cortex
like Swiss cheese okay
good to know during this time I'm still
buying oxy clean to clean all the blood
out of everything buy in bulk I was you
know I would show up at the the counter
and Target and I would have a cart full
of bandages OxiClean
you know I was they must have thought I
was a murderer I don't know I was trying
to you know so you know these these
moments come to mind that stand out you
know standing of the pharmacy counter
with all my bandages in my OxiClean and
whatnot and you know it's it's sort of
an odd experience perhaps unlike other
family traumas throughout this
experience there weren't other moms who
were helping with rides for my other
kids picking kids up at practice provide
meals so to the clinicians that are here
please understand how alone these family
members can be feeling I mean they're
suffering so acutely you know the we
want the best for our loved ones we may
not be able to provide it without your
help
we need your help at one point I you
know went to a therapist myself and
tried to get some help and and trying so
hard to help she was so well intentioned
and so she was she told me in our in our
second session she said I just want you
to understand that your son will never
be able to accomplish what he wants to
do in his life okay thankfully I didn't
believe her so I went to an NEA BPD
family connections class and that
changed the course of our families
experience we learned specific skills
that enabled us to help our son
ourselves and our other children
throughout this whole process we had
lost our confidence in our ability to
have a rich and loving relationship with
our son the relationship mindfulness
skills that we learned in the class
enabled us to walk and work together
with him through the terror and the fear
and the uncertainty that he and our
family experienced over the next several
months learning about validation skills
change the
of our conversations within our home
these were the skills that we had to
learn and practice and as we did our
relationship with our son improved
dramatically his other symptoms and
continued but it was truly a sea change
because we were facing everything
together as a family unit because his
symptoms continued unabated with
self-mutilate self-mutilate mutilation
impulsivity and drug use he ended up
deferring college for his freshman year
culminating in an episode with him
slicing himself open and in such a way
that he hoped to effectively bleed out
again he himself expressed ambivalence
about that he said if I die I die if I
don't I don't so he did end up in
inpatient in acute care for about six
weeks we had to keep coming back to the
skills that we had learned in the family
connections class regarding radical
acceptance of our lives and his so that
we could calmly support him and his
Sybil and his siblings
you know you faced such odds
circumstances okay so my you know my son
is in the hospital in an acute care unit
that you know he's only designed people
would be there for a short period of
time he's there for six weeks meanwhile
I'm back at home and I've got like how
do you get rid of a bloody mattress I
don't know
hmm you don't take it to the dump like
you can't take a blood-soaked mattress
to the dump can you no you can't because
they will think you're hiding a body
somewhere can you put it out by the curb
for bulk pickup no no I'm gonna answer
that one right away can't do that either
so you know these things that you that
your your patients families are going
through that you just can't like they're
just absurd they're absolutely absurd
and they're not the kind of things you
talk to your neighbors about hey listen
I've got this really bloody mattress it
looks off in the carpet the carpet you
know the carpet guys are gonna come in
to replace the carpet in his room while
he's in the hospital but it is blood
soaked and I'm just wondering like
should I have them come take that out
will that scare them or do we have to
you know stay up all night and take out
the carpet
often you know do something with it so
that you know that nobody thinks it was
a crime so all these odd things happen
in any event a turning point another
turning point I will say and you don't
you don't hear much about medication
with BPD but with our son there's so
many things going on at the same time
that finding the right medication truly
was a turning point for him and our
psychiatrist who continued to help us
while he was in the hospital you know
would consult with the psychiatrist at
the hospital would talk to us help
facilitate communication really went out
of his way he called me up he said you
know a study just came out in the
American Journal of Psychiatry you know
this you I really I want to talk to the
psychiatrist on staff to talk about
trying this with your son and everybody
was on board and we tried it and it made
a difference our son describes his
experience with medication as follows he
said that he is like a boat on an ocean
and the ocean you know these these huge
waves of emotion are coming and they're
they're just you know he's this little
boat and it's just it's just at the
mercy of these waves and he said with
the medication it doesn't take away for
him in his unique circumstance it does
not take away the waves but it puts
ballast in the boat so that he is like
this instead of like that and for him
that helped him then enough to be able
to benefit from therapy you know that
our next challenge was where do you go
from the acute care unit not a single
residential facility in the entire
United States would accept him not
Menninger not Sheppard Pratt not Austin
Riggs it's particularly hard because
he's a male he's the boy there's more
you know treatment out there for women
we could not find a single residential
facility that would accept him even
though he was doing much much better so
I was told to just leave him in the
acute care unit for another probably
three months or so until a spot opened
up in the state hospital and that that
would probably be where he would be
living then from that point four
and I was told specifically by the staff
members at the hospital to stop looking
for options for him you know that I'm
not a professional let the let the
discharge planners do their jobs which
they do very well and I appreciate it
tremendously but I was told please stop
that and so I talked to our doctor and
he said don't stop don't stop in fact
I'll help you we were eventually able to
find a program that would accept him it
was not an ideal program however they
would it was something you know any port
in a storm
so and while he was there he was able to
connect with a very gifted psychologist
that could relate to him that could
accept him where he was and help him to
move forward he was there for a couple
of months he came home and continued to
work with that same psychologist twice a
week
it took about another six months for him
to recover sufficiently to being able to
enable him to enroll for his freshman
year at Northeastern he just completed
his freshman year of college at
Northeastern up in Boston other parents
prepare their kids for college by going
to Bed Bath & Beyond and whatnot
we prepared him for college by teaching
him how to check himself into the
emergency room you know he still had a
very difficult year was not the typical
freshman experience you know how many
other freshmen are going to rushing back
to their rooms to have a Skype session
with their psychologist twice a week you
know they you know he goes to class at
you know 10 o'clock in the morning he's
a little bit late because he just was
checked out of the ER a little bit late
so he was a little bit late to class you
know I mean these are not typical
experiences but they're his experience
and he got through it and he got through
it successfully and he is doing what he
wants to do and he's using his emotional
storms you know in his work at school he
is a you know he's in the school of arts
media and design and he is a film
studies major and so he's using his
experiences and he's telling stories
with them and I'm so excited for him and
you know life
it's not easy but it is pretty exciting
and I feel like I just need to give one
more plug for any a PPD before I go I
feel like I should say this this talk
was brought to you by the NEA BPD
because truly attending that class made
the difference that made the difference
so I thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]